and we've got a great health update on
Alex Trebek
he says his cancerous tumors have shrunk
by more than 50 percent and that he's
near remission it's blowing me away the
78 year old reveals that chemotherapy is
working on his Stage four pancreatic
cancer and he tells People magazine that
his doctors haven't seen this kind of
positive result in their memories the
Jeopardy host recently revealed to Jane
Pauley he now wears a wig to hide the
hair loss from the chemo we have the
summer months off so hopefully my own
hair will grow back Alex has also
admitted battling periods of sadness
following his diagnosis but now after
the positive news he tells People quote
I got a little emotional but these were
tears of joy not tears of great
depression despite the only nine percent
survival rate of pancreatic cancer
Alex's upbeat he'll beat it saying quote
we need to be hopeful it doesn't always
have to end in death and in more celeb
health news Sharon Osbourne is going
under the knife confessing on the talk
she's getting plastic surgery again I'll
have a new face churn has opened up in
the past and having three facelifts a
tummy tuck lipo and breast implants put
in and taken out before Christmas
wait her looks have changed dramatically
over the years due to many more nips
lifts and tucks and you gotta love that
she is not shy about sharing it with the
world I never took a picture to a doctor
and said I want to look like Cap'n I
didn't want to look like my mom cuz I
look like my mom and I don't want to
look like my god no duck lips just face
lips
[Music]